after a whole month of the Mac Studios
being out Apple finally updated Final
Cut Pro and with that adobe also updated
Premiere Pro and DaVinci Resolve was
released the latest update not long ago
so we can finally make our ultimate
video editing comparison including three
of these Mac Studio starting with the
two thousand dollar base model the four
thousand dollar mid spec and the top
level performance which has 128 gigs of
RAM and a 64 core Graphics now I tested
out a bunch of different codecs
different tests RAW graphics performance
where it comes to uh video editing
encoding speeds timeline smoothness how
much video streams could be handled this
is the most comprehensive test out there
to help you decide if you should buy one
of these Mac Studios and then which
specifications and configurations you
should get and trust me this is go going
to get interesting let's go ahead and
jump in and I'm only going to have a
couple benchmarks because I'm going to
focus on real world performance but I
need to set the stage when we test out
geekbench 5 as far as metal we see that
there is not that big of a difference in
terms of performance now we have
discovered that geekbench it does not
utilize all these gpus a lot of time
they're just sitting there waiting for
work to come in so this actual
performance is not valid if it was
working properly it would look similar
to gfx bench metal where we go from 241
frames per second all the way to
484. now you guys may see that we don't
get complete proper scaling and that's
was to be expected a little bit but
there are some disappointments now
another test that uses metal is
blackmagic's raw playback test here we
have 200 frames per second for the M1
Max 24 core and then going up to 314 for
the 48 core now it has double the
graphics course so it should be 400
right well no we're not getting that
scaling but then spending an extra
thousand dollars for the 64 core model
we get actually 307. I tested this
multiple times it actually went down a
little bit now these scores are very
impressive for example our five thousand
dollar iMac Pro only runs at 107 frames
per second showing you just how much of
a leap even the base Mac Studio is now
unfortunately the highest end ones well
they're supposed to run at 400 and then
maybe somewhere around 500 or so if the
scaling was proper but they don't now
this is where I have to say once again
just because an application is optimized
for Apple silicon it's Arm based doesn't
mean that it's completely optimized for
these new graphic ships and even the M1
the tile memory uh the way it's set up
for maximum efficiency and dimension
resolve has actually done a killer job
as you guys will see optimizing but
there is more room it to go and boy that
64 car it's interesting now when an
application or task is fully optimized
for example denoising raw video and
DaVinci Resolve this is the difference
that you can expect we get 12 frames per
second playback and this is really tough
denoising both temporal and spatial for
the M1 Max 24 core jump up to 16 for the
48 and then we jump up to 20 for the 64.
now once again you know the mid-spec
four thousand dollar one it should get
double at the performance and we're not
seeing that we're going from 12 to 16
and this is something that is fully
optimized and this shows you the RAW
graphics power as it relates to video
editing which is why I love this test so
if you're going to buy them on Ultra and
if you decide to wait for optimizations
in the future know that you will not get
perfect scaling for what you're paying
for and this is just the true now
jumping into video editing I'm going to
start out with stabilizing a one minute
4K clip and here in Final Cut it is
insanely fast it is so fast in fact and
so optimized that it is limited by the
decoders for this footage now Premiere
Pro it's almost identical as you guys
see that's because it's only using the
CPU and it's only using roughly 25 of it
it uses no Graphics so that is terrible
now as far as DaVinci Resolve yes we do
see some improvement but nothing like
you would expect and this does use 100
GPU power it's not limited it is
optimized so there you guys go that's
the difference you get for spending
close to three times as much money now
as far as editing and exporting your
regular h.264 4K footage you see those
times are so close and they are
identical between the different Mac
models that is just because this footage
is so easy that the extra power gives
you nothing it literally improves
nothing now some people say well maybe
you'll get extra timelines to move this
so we're going to talk about that a lot
well in fact I put in my toughest h.264
test with this four 4K videos in a 4K
timeline with lots and film grain
applied multiple Luts we have color
corrections two are reversed and they
play back perfectly smoothly I literally
stopped using this test for years after
I created it because systems would just
crash or Play Back At One to two frames
per second if they were very powerful
and here it's playing back perfectly and
only using 75 of the GPU meaning there's
an extra 15 for more footage or more
effects and this is with the two
thousand dollar base Mac Studio which is
incredible now when you're actually
editing a timeline there is so much more
overhead for effects and if we're
switching over to h.265 which is a more
modern Kodak we'll hear the export times
are quite a bit faster and DaVinci
Resolve is actually by far the fastest
they've done the most optimizations so
this is kind of the way to go forward
now when you are exporting this and even
though it's exporting at about I don't
know I think it's 150 170 frames per
second
you are still only using 79 of the
graphics power and that is in the two
thousand dollar M1 Max now the M1 Ultras
they do have more overhead but not as
big of a difference as I would expect
because if we're using about 80 for the
M1 Max I would think doubling the
graphics course would allow us to only
use 40 percent but you guys could see
that is not the case now when we are in
the timeline and we are editing
everything is nice and smooth no matter
even if you stack you know a lot of
effects and color Corrections it works
super well in all of these programs now
some people say well what about
multi-cam well I actually took 15 4K
streams put it in a 4K timeline and they
each had their own color Corrections and
multiple Luts and that's how much it
took in order to use 95 of the graphics
that is just incredible it blew my mind
so I wish I had a system like this back
like maybe three years ago when I
stopped doing wedding filmmaking and
editing multicam I mean it is just so
smooth just proving that with this
footage you do not need to have an M1
Ultra now some people do there are
dropped frames in titles and animation
especially with plugins and that is true
but guess what it still happens with the
M1 Ultra as well that's just because the
plugins aren't optimized yet there's
glitches and bugs and it is really
annoying but it doesn't mean that if you
buy an M1 Ultra it's going to solve that
issue that is still there people have to
update their plugins now as far as Canon
R5 422 10-bit footage this is what makes
my 15 000 Mac Pro choke up same thing
with previous Intel Max well this
footage plays just as well as other easy
4K footage it is incredible as far as
smoothness I wanted to stack as much
effects as I could to get it to slow
down so I literally stacked 10 Luts on
there regular color correction I did
white balance adjustments Hue to Hue and
it literally played back at like 75 or
77 percent G P usage it didn't even Max
it out perfectly smooth and that is
coming from about 43 percent before not
a big jump with all those effects and
then I stacked on top of it another
layer with masking with animated text
and that was still only 83 Graphics
usage and that is with the base M1 Max
it is crazy now when we're exporting
this footage this is crazy you guys see
it takes two minutes for a five minute
project
for all of these literally all of them
and I actually tested this out using
prores as well and we were limited and
that just tells me that with this
particular codec we are actually limited
by the decoders that work with this
footage that also means that no you will
not be able to have 15 streams of uh 4K
10 bit 422 you're gonna be more limited
to about I think about six to seven
which is still incredible so
realistically for all this footage it is
just crazy the M1 Max is amazing and you
are not going to miss out now as far as
raw footage well this is where you start
getting some extra benefit from the
ultra and the extra graphics and
especially in some tests the CPU power I
tested out Blackmagic raw this is 6k
intervention resolve with color
Corrections and multiple Luts and this
is where the M1 Ultra starts to come in
you guys see the exporting is quite a
bit bit quicker this is a five minute
project as well not twice as fast but
closer and what really stands out to me
is the fact that this is GPU limited
it's raw using all of the performance
being maximized really well but the 64
core still doesn't perform much better
than the 48 and when we are in the
timeline this black magic raw is
extremely smooth it is so so smooth and
as far as the GPU usage our M1 Max uses
39 percent for 6K with color Corrections
in multiple Luts and we go down to 25
for the 48 core and only 21 for the 64.
so the 64. 50 more course they're still
being used a lot as far as the total
usage we're not getting that much extra
performance here or overhead for extra
effects now this means that the base
model can handle two streams of 6K
Blackmagic route with the facts and
Corrections or about five streams if
you're using four 4K that is really good
and then if you lower your resolution or
your playback or your multi-cam with
everything full screen it can actually
do more than that the ultra it won't
able be able to do double but it'll be
able to do close to that so you guys can
make your decision for this codec with
this program that's very well optimized
for this and for example the 64 core
definitely I would not be spending the
extra for that and now let's get into
some even tougher tests testing out
Canon 4K Cinema raw Lite this is where
stuff gets crazy and we start seeing
some massive differences both in the
systems and also the programs now I
exported a five minute project and I
want to reiterate that I'm using a
shorter project because I'm spending so
much time days benchmarking and with
these systems none of them have any
throttling or slow down so you can
literally take your project say you work
on 15 minute projects and just triple
these times to see how much time you
will save now Premiere Pro is slow as
you guys see much lower than Final Cut
and then DaVinci Resolve is incredibly
fast this just shows us how these
programs deal with this footage and for
example instead of buying an M1 Ultra
you can literally switch from Premiere
Pro go to DaVinci Resolve and the base
Max studio will be literally twice as
fast and unlike our previous compressed
Kodak tests here the expert times also
show you how this footage performs when
you're editing and how many streams you
can use for example the reason Premiere
so slow is because it is limited by the
CPU not the graphics which is why the
faster 64 core M1 Ultra it doesn't
really give you any benefits now as far
as that playback in Premiere the base
model only plays back at 17 frames per
second and then if you get the M1 Ultra
the 20 core CPU you go up to 30 6 frames
per second meaning you can only play
back one stream of this footage either
24 or 30 FPS with some basic color
Corrections a lot and have proper
performance you can't do any better than
that without having to make some sort of
compromises now in Final Cut even the
base model can play back at up to 60
frames per second and the weaker thing
is upgrading you don't get that much
more performance so keep that in mind if
you use Final Cut but in DaVinci Resolve
look at the optimizations that they made
that is incredible I just want to you
know just clap for The DaVinci Resolve
team but with that I still don't think
it's worth spending the extra thousand
dollars for the 64 core M1 Ultra and
with that let's switch to 8K Cannon Rod
this is less compressed here and in
DaVinci Resolve the M1 Ultras can
actually play this back perfectly in 8k
with a light applied and color
Corrections now in Final Cut it does not
play back perfectly it does so smooth
but of course you can lower down to a
worse quality just like that in
Adventures of you can also go down to a
4K timeline and then even the M1 Max
will play it back before Premiere Pro
even the M1 Ultra can only place back at
four frames per second and two frames
per second for the Mac Studio once again
showing if you can change from Premiere
to resolve you will have much bigger
improvements than upgrading to the
highest and Mac Studio now as far as
export times we see pretty linear
scaling going from the M1 Max to the M1
Ultra but with that the 64 core Ultra
model doesn't really get much faster
than the 48 core and that is because we
are actually limited by the CPU and I
would just say for this kind of footage
I think that the 4000 Mac Studio is a
perfect sweet spot because you get a lot
of improvements compared to the base
model now for those of you guys that
work with Pro
I have multiple tests for you first off
I have to say for the prores route we're
only using Final Cut and Premiere Pro
because DaVinci Resolve does not support
it unfortunately but the performance of
these programs it's amazing super smooth
even for the raw with less color
Corrections facts it is incredible and
exporting a five minute project it just
flies with all these systems now one
Trend that I'm seeing is that you don't
get that much more performance for the
M1 Ultra because there's dedicated
decoders that are taking the load off of
the CPU and Graphics so all of that
extra uh you know performance is just
there for effects now Final Cut is a lot
more efficient
um it uses a lot less GPU power you have
a lot more overhead but with that I mean
both are still super fast now switching
over to 8K prores raw to prores 444 xq
here I just used Final Cut and once
again you see that the times are so
similar here and that just shows me that
because of these specific decoders the
prores hardware the Apple built in that
is for free in here they're kind of
shooting themselves in the foot because
even the base Mac Studio is so
incredibly quick even with AK prores raw
it is crazy and in fact it can handle
about four streams of AK prores raw or
maybe about five to six of 8K prores it
is insane and that's the base model now
as far as just regular prores that is
just so easy now so I'm just using 8K
you guys see the export times right here
this one has resolve of course resolve
is the quickest but once again we're not
seeing a huge difference between the
different models so if you're working
with processor produce raw just get
yourself the base model maybe upgraded
32 Graphics cores if you want a little
bit more overhead with the M1 Max you
will be super happy and and the last
thing we have on our list is red AK raw
now as far as playback unfortunately
none of these systems can play it back
perfectly the Ultras get close
especially in DaVinci Resolve but once
you start adding some Luts some color
Corrections you just don't have enough
performance there now as far as the M1
Max you see it is pretty much half the
performance and that's because this is
something that is both CPU and GPU
limited it is very very tough and as far
as exports the scaling is also pretty
close there as far as improvements and
performance now in Premiere Pro we
actually had to go down to a quarter
resolution to get proper scaling in
Final Cut and resolve you can just go
into the 4K timeline and then it will
play back smooth as far as the base
model but personally I would say if
you're dealing with AK red raw or the 8K
Cannon raw you just have to get yourself
an M1 Ultra and once again the extra
performance from the 64 core model
doesn't give you enough to make it worth
a thousand dollars so unless money
doesn't matter realistically for these
really tough codecs the raw codecs the
MN Ultra 4 000 model is awesome but for
everything else including you know your
compressed
h.2640265s your black magic raw uh if
you have proraz man that base model the
m and Max maybe upgraded a bit if you
want to is so so fast as far as playback
smoothness effects all of that so there
you guys go I hope I made some of you
guys uh comforted if you guys didn't buy
the high-end one because realistically
most people don't need it especially
YouTube creators and if you're somebody
that does want the extra performance
well hopefully you didn't buy the
highest end model because stuff isn't
working too well now maybe in the
upcoming years we will see optimizations
of course Premiere Pro you saw in many
of those projects uh the the tough ones
they there is just so much slower than
the other two programs hopefully they
improve it some more and if they don't
well consider looking at DaVinci Resolve
it just works incredibly incredibly well
so well that it actually doesn't slow
down in our torture tests and runs at
the full 1300 megahertz or right there
next to it compared to dropping out a
900 megahertz for the 4 000.48 core M1
Ultra and Final Cut so yes Final Cut is
less optimized even for the specific
tiled memory of the Apple silicon chips
which is why it's bottlenecked and the
graphics are slowing down then DaVinci
Resolve wow guys I never thought I would
see the day where Apple software is not
capable of not optimized well for its
Hardware but DaVinci resolves is so
there you guys go thank you for watching
hope you guys enjoyed it click that
Circle above to subscribe to help us
make more insanely detailed videos like
this one check out one of those great
ones right over there that's been Max
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]